en division 1 le rapporteur sur les deux
amendements oui monsieur le président
donc effectivement ces deux amendements
sont très antinomique j'ai envie de dire
le premier le 40 qui prévoit l'extension
extinction progressive de la retraite
supplémentaire par capitalisation
je rappelle que la retraite
supplémentaire constitue le troisième
étage de notre système d'assurance
vieillesse elle n'a pas vocation à se
substituer à la retraite obligatoire de
base et complémentaires mais s'ajoute
facultativement à ces dernières donc
c'est un avis défavorable de la
commission sur cet amendement
l'amendement 246 qui vise à mentionner
l'existence des trois étages du système
de retraite les retraites de base les
retraites complémentaires et les
retraites supplémentaires
cet amendement ne précise pas les
objectifs du système de retraites mais
son organisation qui est un moyen au
service de ses objectifs pour cette
raison la commission a émis un avis
défavorable à cet amendement
l'avis du gouvernement la ministre je
donne un avis défavorable aux deux
amendements qui recherchent des
objectifs
radim radicalement au diamétralement
opposées je veux rappeler que pour le
gouvernement il ne s'agit en aucun cas
de mettre en place un système de
retraite par capitalisation y compris de
façon partielle l'enjeu est bien de
mettre de consolider notre système de
répartition de telle sorte qu'il
garantisse à chacun en regard de sa
carrière professionnelle et des
mécanismes de solidarité qu'ils
interviennent un niveau de retraite
décente et digne
dans le même temps si nos concitoyens
souhaitent pouvoir constituer une
épargne complémentaire dans la
perspective de leur retraite
nous n'avons aucune raison de nous y
opposer dès lors que ces mécanismes de
retraite souscrit individuellement par
exemple les perco en entreprise mais dès
lors que c'est
mécanisme de retraite sont souscrits
individuellement et ne viennent pas
comment dire se substituer à la retraite
par répartition nous ne voulons pas
aller à l'encontre de la liberté
contractuelle de la liberté individuelle
pour chacun nos concitoyens de
constituer une épargne qui viendra en
complément de la retraite qui lui sera
servi par notre mécanisme par
répartition et c'est pour la raison pour
laquelle je donne aussi un avis
défavorable à l'amendement présenté par
le groupe crc
merci double abonnement 40
explications de vote cela fait déjà
quelques temps qu'une certaine partie du
patronat notamment dans la banque et
dans l'assurance
quelques idéologues de l'institut de
l'entreprise ou l'institut montaigne
présente la capitalisation comme la
panacée aux mots rédhibitoire notre
système de retraite par répartition dont
l'avenir serait d'être indéfiniment
déficit grandissant
alors je crois qu'il faut un moment
donné revenir aux fondamentaux même de
ce qu'est la capitalisation des
fondamentaux exactement inverse on peut
le dire notre système solidaire de
retraite
en effet avec le système de la
capitalisation l'intérêt des actifs qui
veulent épargner et de disposer de
revenus élevés sur lesquels ils peuvent
soustraire des sommes au delà de leur
consommation et dans le même temps
l'intérêt des rentiers retraités
d'obtenir la meilleure rémunération
immédiate de leur capital investi en
clair le système par capitalisation pose
donc clairement les actifs aux retraités
la persistance des outils de
capitalisation conduit à pérenniser
notre système de retraites mais cet
antagonisme entre actifs et retraités de
plus la capitalisation des sert
l'intérêt général en effet la logique
globale de la capitalisation tient dans
un accroissement continu du capital et
dans une progression du rendement du
capital à ce titre c'est un système qui
jouent contre la consommation et contre
l'emploi le prélèvement opéré un moment
donné
sur les richesses produites et retiré de
la consommation il me revient qu'après
un circuit long et fortement hasardeuse
le système par capitalisation en effet
plein d'aléas les placements opérés
aujourd'hui peuvent ne pas se révéler
judicieux
quelques années plus tard il s'agit bien
de confier sa retraite à la bourse cela
n'est pas très rassurant et tout le
monde peut en juger aujourd'hui compte
tenu des fluctuations voire des crises
boursières
ainsi la capitalisation peut paraître
rentable quand il ya montée en puissance
du système comme par exemple la demande
d'actifs financiers est importante c'est
à dire quand les actifs sont nombreux en
période d'épargné capitalisation mais à
l inverse quand les personnes arrivent à
l'âge de la retraite elles ont tendance
à vouloir liquider leur pension
très logiquement veulent vivre sur leur
capital et vont vendre une partie de
leurs avoirs qui sera offerte sur les
marchés si alors il y a moins de jeunes
et de revenus pour acheter ses titres la
tendance du marché sur à la baisse en
conclusion ces titres vont s'effondrer
ni les retraités ni les actifs ne
pourront bénéficier des bienfaits
supposés de la capitalisation
il ressort donc de ce qui précède que le
recours à la capitalisation n'empêche
pas les effets du fameux choc
démographique on y revient qu'elle vous
vous référez pour l'imposer la
capitalisation n'est efficace ni pour
créer la solidarité ni pour répondre aux
variations démographiques ni pour
engendrer du revenu elle n'est efficace
que pour organiser sa disparition c'est
bien les biens c'est bel et bien pour
ces motifs de fond que nous vous
proposons l'adoption de cet amendement
merci aux explications de vote sauf deux
hommes sont longues et c'est cet
amendement là sur le 40
non je suis aux 40 pour d'autres
explications votre sur 40 donc je
rappelle que la commission et les
gouvernements mis des buts défavorable
cet amendement ceux qui sont favorables
seulement de m'en veulent bien levez la
main ceux qui sont défavorables cet
amendement il n'est pas d'adopter un
amendement 246 monsieur longuet
monsieur le président madame le ministre
mes chers collègues nous sommes un
rendez vous important de la réflexion
collective sur l'avenir de nos retraites
il n'est pas complètement inutile de
revenir en effet en arrière si les
régimes par capitalisation ont connu
dans notre pays au lendemain de la
deuxième guerre mondiale une image
négative
rappelons qu'il ya eu quand même deux
événements importants qui ont marqué
l'histoire monétaire française
la première guerre mondiale dont nous
allons marquer le centenaire du
déclenchement l'année prochaine et la
seconde guerre mondiale que j'évoquais
incidemment la première guerre mondiale
a mis fin à un siècle de stabilité
monétaire pendant lequel les
travailleurs pour les salariés
minoritaires pour les travailleurs
indépendants et notamment le monde
agricole mais le monde à commerciales
artisanales ont pu se constituer des
retraites par capitalisation ça
s'appelait des rentiers et les rentiers
était d'ailleurs assez nombreux dans
notre pays qui entre la rampe d'état
d'une part ou l'immobilier d'autre part
accédait après une période de vie de
labeur à une certaine indépendance
7 cette retraite par capitalisation qui
n'était pas formalisé a évidemment été
balayé par l'inflation
issue de la première guerre mondiale et
toutes les tentatives de stabilisation
ont rendu cette situation tu es le
rentier qui a disparu sociologiquement
de notre pays en 1945
en effet le cener a lancé un nous
sortent nouveau contrat social
la répartition est l'enfant de
l'inflation la répartition est l'enfant
de l'inflation puisqu'il s'agit de payer
immédiatement des retraites avec les
ressources des cotisations ce qui a
évoqué rené paul savary précédemment et
de et de ne surtout de rien attendre et
de faire en sorte que les retraites
versées correspondent aux cotisations
immédiatement
or ces tentes la fuite devant la monnaie
en raison de la risque du risque
permanent d'inflation rendait tout
système de capitalisation à peu près
impossible qui d'ailleurs pas empêché un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes qui
avaient des revenus légèrement supérieur
qui pouvait dégager une marge ou qui
pouvaient accéder au crédit d'échapper à
l'inflation et de se constituer une
retraite par l'accumulation d'actifs
notamment d'actifs immobiliers qui eux
étaient des biens réels protéger de
l'inflation
le salarié ou le retraité courant après
l'inflation selon la vieille formule des
syndicalistes les prix prennent
l'ascenseur et les salaires prennent
l'escalier aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
une situation française qui a simplement
complètement changé ce pour deux raisons
la première c'est que nous appartenons à
une monnaie nouvelle l'euro dont
l'objectif est de stabilité on peut
regretter cet objectif
on peut au contraire s'en féliciter mais
c'est un fait que depuis que l'euro est
mise en place et la majorité de cette
assemblée souhaite maintenir
l'appartenance de la france en euros
nous avons une stabilité et donc le
regard d'une nos compatriotes à face à
la sécurité des vieux jours changent
parce que change également la relation
qu'ils ont avec la monnaie en dans la
mesure même où l'inflation a disparu
c'est un premier élément dont vous ne
pouvez pas ne pas te dire qu'on deuxième
élément extrêmement important et je suis
très étonné madame le ministre que vous
ne nie réfléchissiez pas publiquement
c'est la globalisation la globalisation
économique mondiale a des avantages et
des inconvénients que se passe-t-il avec
une régime de répartition ce régime de
répartition est nécessairement
exclusivement nationales puisque
évidemment l'autorité de la loi ne peut
jouer qu'à l'intérieur d'un espace de
l'espace national qui est l'espace de
l'imperium de la loi or pourquoi priver
les générations de français
d'aujourd'hui de la capacité
deux performances économiques de
développement et de croissance qui
apparaissent dans d'autres parties du
monde et que seul l'investissement
français à l'extérieur à travers des
capitalisations permettrait de rapatrier
dans notre pays après tout la france
vieillit contrairement à ce que vous
pensez il y a des petits jeunes qui sont
en puissance en expansion
l'intérêt bien compris des jeunes
générations françaises à venir
ce serait d'associer leurs économies
lors prévoyance au développement de pays
qui ont des perspectives affichées de
croissance alors que malheureusement et
vous le donner dans notre dans votre
rapport un taux de croissance de l'ordre
de 1 et demi pour cent par an pour les
20 prochaines années dans ce pays c'est
un taux extrêmement raisonnable ce café
l'a rappelé en commission mais c'est un
taux qui est très largement inférieure à
la performance économique
d'autres parties du monde alors je ne
nie pas qu'il y ait dans la démarche de
capitalisation la possible la
perspective d'un risque mais et
guillaume hily a également la
perspective d'un succès lorsque nous
rappelons ce principe de capitalisation
ne voulons pas simplement dire une
évidence madame le ministre évidence que
vous avez rappelé c'est que chacun
d'entre nous a droit à l épargne et à se
constituer une épargne et si possible en
ne payant pas un impôt sur cette épargne
alors qu'il a déjà des payer un impôt
sur le revenu
mais pourquoi priver la collectivité
française de la perspective d'être
associée par des placements collectifs
judicieux à la réussite d'autres parties
du monde auquel nous souhaitons
d'ailleurs la croissance puisque
prolétaires et consommateurs de tous les
pays unissez vos pour une croissance
harmonieuse et pacifique dans le monde
j'ai usé mon temps de parole oui tout à
fait je ne vois pas d'autres trucs comme
ça
oui monsieur le président de la ministre
mes chers collègues vous ne serez pas
surpris je compléterai je partage bien
évidemment l'analyse de gérard longuet
et je veux redire
d'abord je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
l'importance que j'accorde à ces trois
piliers d'abord pour une raison tout à
fait pratique c'est que si vous essayez
quand vous prenez par exemple un
tabouret à trois pattes ça assure
toujours la stabilité des systèmes où
que vous soyez ça c'est pour le clin
d'oeil mais pour rester tout à fait
sérieux on a rappelé l'attachement qui
était le nôtre au principe de la
répartition c'est bien le premier pilier
les deux les deux autres piliers
c'est à la fois les régimes de retraite
collectifs pour certaines de profession
alors elle existe elle a existé elle
existe toujours pour les fonctionnaires
jeu juste faire un rappel pour celles et
ceux qui sont ou étaient fonctionnaires
et qui ont éventuellement cotiser il ne
vous a pas échappé à quelques années que
ce système qui était présenté comme
partir mans vertueux s'est révélé
présentait des trous puisque à la fois
par des erreurs de gestion et
globalement s je lis un peu par rapport
au système de points puisque ça rejoint
me semble-t-il mêmes préoccupations
finalement
celles et ceux qui ont à ce moment-là
cotisé ont été victimes alors à la fois
des erreurs de gestion mais surtout ont
vu par rapport à leurs versements
les prestations n'ont pas défini comme
vous le demandiez dans votre premier
amendement mais les prestations diminué
ce qui ne doit pas manquer de nous
interroger
mais puisque jeudi pour préfon je peux
aussi dire un mot des contrats madelin
les contrats madelin me semble répondent
parfaitement aux objectifs de complément
de retraite puis ce qu'ils associent les
indépendants dont on sait qu en général
leurs cotisations ne leur permettent pas
rapport à la pyramide des âges de
pouvoir par le seul régime par
répartition bénéficier de retraite
décente correspondant globalement à la
proportionnalité de revenus l'avantagent
des contrats madelin c'est que vous avez
des sorties obligatoires en rente
on est donc bien sûr des dispositifs de
retraite collectives complémentaires
et puis le troisième pilier auxquels
nous sommes attachés
il faut le rappeler c'est une forme des
formes différencier de retraite
individuelle on en cite quelques unes
que ce soit aujourd'hui le perp là aussi
où nous sortons en rente donc il s'agit
absolument pas va dire de dispositifs de
capitalisation sort en capital c'est de
la rente
on est donc bien sûr système de
retraites mais si on regarde un peu dans
le rétroviseur il ya mieux encore il y
avait mieux il ya quelques années que le
perp
ça s'appelait le peps le plan d'epargne
populaire pourquoi il était plus
intéressant parce qu'il répondait à la
même logique mais il permettait
finalement une récompense sur les
efforts de celui ou de celle qui
acceptaient au long de sa vie de faire
un effort d'épargné individuelle c'est
qui vous permettait de sortir en rente
avec une rente net d'impôt alors dieu
merci madame la ministre j'espère que
vous allez nous rassurer j'espère que
dans les mesures que vous annoncez qui
me paraissent
et dans un très mauvais sens sur la
nouvelle fiscalité de certains contrats
d'assurance-vie retraite
j'espère que vous ne remettrez pas en
cause d'ailleurs à mon humble avis ça ne
serait pas constitutionnel
cette caractéristique pour les contrats
qui existent toujours et qui permettent
de pouvoir sortir en rente net d'impôt
ça veut donc dire qu'on peut avoir la
retraite par répartition c'est l'effort
collectif
et puis les efforts collectifs sous
forme de rente par le biais
d'entreprises
c'est le second pilier les régimes de
retraite supplémentaire collectif me
semble-t-il on est toujours dans une
forme de solidarité bien comprise et
enfin pour celles et ceux qui dans
l'arbitrage de l'horreur et en fonction
de leur capacité contributive souhaite
constituer un complément de retraite on
autorise bien avec des facultés y
compris les avantages fiscaux des
investissements dans l'immobilier
il me paraît en tout les cas normal sain
et salutaire de pouvoir autoriser
toujours cette capitalisation
personnelles sur des actions parce que
dans le temps en tous les cas c'est ce
type de produit qui offre la meilleure
rentabilité
et puis dois je le rappeler ça nous
permet aussi d'alimenter le bon
fonctionnement de l'économie française
donc je ne doute pas
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
que vous saurez vous ranger à nos
arguments pour soutenir cet amendement
numéro 2 146 merci monsieur café oui
monsieur le président je crois qu'avec
ces deux amendements le précédent qui a
été repoussée le 40 et
celui qui est en discussion à l'heure
actuelle 246 nous sommes en plein débat
dogmatique et d'ordre idéologique
je n'étais pas favorable à l'amendement
parce que je ne vois pas pourquoi il ne
pourriez ne pourrait pas exister un
certain nombre de produits d'épargné
faisant appel à la capitalisation est
d'ailleurs votre amendement poser un
certain nombre de problèmes
comment dénouer les contraintes existent
déjà
comment y mettre fin enfin être
remboursés et comment dans quelles
conditions
monsieur à qui on disait ben vous n'avez
plus le droit de contribuer à tel ou tel
produit
c'était le premier sujet deuxième sujet
et c'était le gouvernement qui était
chargée en fait dénouer cette situation
compliquée deuxième sujet c'est bon ou
est-ce qu'on mettait la barre qu'est ce
qui ressortait de la capitalisation et
qu'est-ce qui ne ressortait pas est-ce
que l'assurance vie par exemple
ressortir de la capitalisation
fallait-il mettre fin aux contrats
d'assurance vie à l'ensemble des
contrats d'assurance vie ou un certain
nombre d'entre eux
on voit bien qu'on tombait dans des
problèmes totalement inextricable ceci
pour l'amendement 40 mais enfin il a été
rejetée alors l'amendement 246 yeux j'ai
bien entendu le plaidoyer de de notre
collègue le gérard longuet et j'ai
préféré la fin de son intervention au
début parce que j'ai craint un moment
donné qu'il était en quelque sorte
nostalgiques du rentier d'avant guerre
et quand je suis dit avant guerre
c'était celui d'avant guerre de 14 pas
de la rengaine de 40
et ma foi bon le l'apologie que vous
l'avez fait de ce rentier
avisé de la fin du 19e ou de début du
deuxième jusqu'avant qu'ils ne soient
ruinées par la crise de 1930 non par
l'entre-deux-guerres
dans l'entre-deux-guerres il a déjà été
ruinée dans l'entre-deux-guerres et là
où j'ai une divergence avec vous c'est
que ce n'était pas en raison de
l'inflation
c'était en raison et je crois que c'est
la limite des régimes par capitalisation
les problèmes des régimes par
capitalisation ou par capitalisation
ce n'est pas un problème d'inflation ce
n'est pas un problème d'érosion de
l'epargne par l'inflation c'est un
problème de rendement des actifs et
personne n'a réussi à démontrer jusqu'à
présent que à long terme le rendement
des actifs c'est à dire un régime par
capitalisation était supérieur à un
régime par répartition
bano mais non et non et d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs
si tel avait été le cas si tel avait été
le cas
non mais je ne dis pas que un certain
nombre de produits des pannes comme l'a
dit la ministre d'ailleurs puissent être
utilisés pour sa retraite
moi ça ne me gêne absolument pas bon ce
qui ce que je conteste c'est que le
régime par capitalisation tels que vous
présentez et des performances qui soit
au moins équivalente est en tout cas
supérieure d'après ce que vous dites
aurélie par répartition je pense que ce
n'est pas vrai et que sur le long terme
le rendement des actifs et au mieux
nulle en tout cas sur une vie et sur une
vie de cotisation ce que vous pouvez
tirer de placement est a priori quelque
chose qui tend vers zéro baisse est ce
que c'est ce que montre c'est ce que
montre à écouter c'est ce que montrent
les rendements regardez leur en manque
de la préfon bon roman regardez le
nombre de la préfon est-ce que la préfon
est-ce que la préfon est un régime par
capitalisation
particulièrement bon
compétitif ça n'est pas le cas ça n'est
pas le cas mais c'est un régime par
capitalisation oui ou non d'accord
adacore pas simplement passer simplement
et donc
donc voilà je bon très franchement on
puisse proposer des produits d'épargné
qui peuvent servir à la retraite d'un
certains nombres de nos concitoyens je
n'y vois vraiment rigoureusement aucun
inconvénient
mais écrire dans la loi parce que c'est
de ça dont il s'agit
écrire dans la loi que la capitalisation
est un étage je dirais presque
obligatoire même si vous prenez la
précaution de dire le cas échéant de
notre système de retraite
c'est un pas personnellement que je
serai franchir alors bien évidemment ça
existe eh bien laissons les vivre mais
ne l'inscrit vont pas dans la loi quand
même monsieur longuet donc nous a parlé
longuement du régime par capitalisation
moi je voudrais juste donné une
information une information 4,5 pour
cent du montant total des cotisations
sociales sont détournés vers la
capitalisation au détriment de la
sécurité sociale soit une bagatelle de
perte de 10 milliards d'euros
et puis poursuivant ce toujours sur sur
le régime par capitalisation puisque
faut pas bouder un débat quand il est
intéressant les banques n'ont pas
confiance dans leur système car dans la
capitalisation les systèmes sont
uniquement à cotisations définies
s'il avait confiance dans leur système
il proposerait des systèmes à
prestations définies
ce n'est pas le cas ils font supporter
les risques uniquement aux assauts aux
assurés tandis que n'entraîne aucun donc
voilà les quelques mots que je voulais
donner dans le débat pour balayer le
système de capitalisation
merci monsieur de médailles
merci monsieur le président madame
ministre et sa collègue je m'étais bien
promis de ne pas intervenir sur ses
seins sur ces amendements qui peuvent
quelquefois sont des amendements
pléonasme qui n'apporte pas grand chose
mais là sur ces deux amendements
je me sens obligé mais je viens apporter
mon concours lorsque la notre système
par répartition a été créé à la
libération était basée sur deux mots le
dépendant de l'autre le premier mot le
plus important c'est le mot solidarité
et le deuxième qui lie à la solidarité
c'est l'obligation et ce 4 de l'article
premier traite de systèmes de retraite
obligatoire et je pense qu'on aurait dû
compléter ce 4e dû être complété en
employant le mot obligatoires le choix
de leur retraite obligatoire par
répartition
encore que encore que la notion
d'obligation est tout de même contenu au
coeur dans le membre de phrase au coeur
du pacte social qui unit les générations
entre elles on a ajouté en train entre
temps je pense que ce membre de phrase
démontre bien que c'est la partie
obligatoire si bien que les deux
amendements traite d'un sujet de deux
sujets au complètement opposés mais qui
n'ont pas ce caractère obligatoire et y
s'éloigne du sujet qui nous intéresse
dans ce 4 en ce qui concerne la la
répartition ou la capitalisation chacun
raconter son histoire à sa façon
mais le mot capitalisation n'est pas un
gros mot
il a même été ce système a été employé
et je les dis dans mon intervention a
été utilisée avant même la répartition
et vous seriez surpris de lire quand on
connaît un peu l'histoire de la création
du système par répartition à la
libération
vous serez peut-être surpris de
constater que c'est un sujet qui a été
l'objet d'un débat très très fort et
très difficile parce qu'il y avait
figuré vous il y avait les tenants de la
capitalisation
je ne vais pas vous dire qui mais je
peux vous le dire était partisan de la
capitalisation entre autres les filles
au jeu commence par la lazio la cgt les
mineurs les mineurs liminaire pourquoi
parce qu'ils avaient eu le un régime qui
existent et qui était un régime par
capitalisation et quittant régime auquel
il tenait il tenait à ce régime par
capitalisation et ils ont lâché
ils ont lâché la capitalisation pour
accepter le système par répartition mais
en contrepartie ils ont gagné le fait
que c'était pas un régime unique
je crois que c'est je tiens à faire ce
rappel parce que j'ai un peu vécu ça ça
m'a été transmis autour de la table
familiale je vous remercie
merci monsieur savary
je crois que monsieur le président
madame la ministre nous sommes vraiment
dans dans le vif du sujet et tous les
éléments historiques qui ont été abordés
par nos collègues sur tout à fait
intéressant je crois que la résultante
de cette discussion est bien qu'il ne
faille pas mettre tous ses oeufs dans le
même panier
ce que l'on vous propose à travers sa
s'être allemande mans je me permets de
vous le relire ses c'est très simple 1
c'est le système de retraite français
composé des régimes de base obligatoire
par répartition et ça je crois que
là-dessus c'est incontestable s'est
largement partagé par l'ensemble des
sénateurs de de tous les bancs des
régimes de retraites complémentaires
obligatoires
et là aussi on peut pas les remettre en
cause et le cas échéant des régimes par
capitalisation à travers notamment les
pagnes retraite collectives ou
individuelles
le cas échéant je crois que c'est
important nos concitoyens ont besoin de
transparence ont besoin de confiance et
c'est véritablement pas le signe que
vous leur donnez madame le ministre
d'autant plus les remises en cause
régulièrement la stabilité fiscale avec
des mesures rétroactives par rapport à
tous ces placements là c'est ça qui est
dangereux c'est ça qui effraye nos
concitoyens il est important à travers
cet article 1er et les objectifs définis
de rappeler les efforts qu'ont fait
certains et les garanties qu'ils doivent
obtenir pour avoir une retraite décente
merci même une bonne le ministre
monsieur le président chers collègues
quand on entend nos collègues de l'ump
turrel il revient au galop
il revient au galop
moi je veux bien qu'on m'explique tous
deux sur l'histoire des différentes
phases
mais en tout cas il ya une position
constante de la gauche depuis la
libération nous sommes défavorables
un régime de capitalisation fut-elle
marginal nous sommes pour un régime de
répartition
ça ne veut pas dire que les français
vont pas placer de l'argent quand ils
ont de l'argent de côté et des économies
qui au moment de leur retraite le
rapport du beurre dans les épinards
ça a toujours existé mais ça n'est pas
la même chose que de mettre en place un
régime de capitalisation car la
capitalisation cantalien en complément
de la de la répartition finit par manger
la répartition parce que ceux qui
doivent le peuvent doivent contribuer
fortement et qui peuvent placer de
l'argent trouve illégitime que il taillé
pour les autres puisque ça leur rapporte
plus
en plaçant leur argent et on voit tous
les exemples qui ont fait un système
mixte ont fini par basculer par plus de
capitalisation et moins de répartition
pour une raison simple c'est la seule
chose qui ait arrêté récemment pour ça
que vous êtes un peu plus modéré c'est
qu'avec la crise qu'on a connu et bien
tout ce qu'avait des retraites parquet
par capitalisation
dans les autres pays se sont retrouvés
dépouillé alors d'un seul coup là vous
êtes un peu plus nuancé
mais dès que le capital va reprendre sa
financiarisation si on n'y arrive pas
vous
le choix fondamental c'est qu'à partir
du moment où une retraite par
capitalisation et on le voit bien que
les fonds de pension qui arrivent en
france c'est qu'il faut un rendement
élevé et donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
légitimer le prélèvement capitalistique
soit supérieur aux prélèvements sur le
travail alors que contre nassiet sur
d'autres critères que la capitale
mieux rémunérés
pour pouvoir financer les retraites il
ya donc deux fait qu'une solidarité de
générations entre des salariés
plus prélevés pour rémunérer le capital
pour payer les retraites de deux des
anciens 7
fondamental dans notre république depuis
la libération alors on peut être en tout
les mots pouvaient la réalité de celles
là la gauche elle parti socialiste sont
hostiles à toute mise de doigts dans le
vert la capitalisation les systèmes
existants existe il ne faut pas les
développer il ne faut pas les aider
fiscalement
je ne pense pas qu'il soit facile de
revenir en arrière mais en tout cas tout
qui permettrait le développement de la
capitalisation est un danger mortel pour
la répartition
donc je voudrais évidemment contre
l'amendement qui est proposé par
monsieur longuet sur le compte
oui je voudrais m'inscrire en continuité
de ce que j'ai dit à notre collègue mme
anodina monsieur le président parce que
avec deux remarques
la première c'est qu'un certain nombre
de pays d'europe centrale tu mis en
place une part de capitalisation dans
leur retraite comme vous le suggérez
finalement revienne en arrière et
regardant derrière pour une raison
simple c'est lorsqu'il n'ya pas assez
d'argent pour financer la partie par
répartition c'est le déficit public
les déficits publics qui se creusent et
qui se creuse pour tous les citoyens au
profit de ceux qui ont un régime par
capitalisation est de ceux qui ont le
plus capitalisées par conséquent c'est
un système qui est un système qui creuse
les déficits publics quand les comptes
publics ne sont pas équilibrés la
deuxième chose c'est que quelle est
cette société qui au lieu d'appeler à la
solidarité dirait dirai aux aux gens aux
citoyens à ceux qui cotisent pour leur
retraite que finalement une génération
le à un pays qui progressent le travail
de toute une vie ne permettrait pas au
bout d'avoir une société meilleure
d'avoir une impétueuse aprogressé
suffisamment pour à la fin d'une vie de
travail permettre de payer une retraite
et qui ôte au lieu de ça diraient que
chacun pense à sa propre retraite par
soi-même sans compter sur la solidarité
ce n'est pas possible
ce n'est pas une société si vous croyez
à la valeur travail
si vous croyez à la valeur travail si
vous croyez à la solidarité il faut
absolument garder entier s en faisant un
choix clair et précis la répartition
parce que c'est ce choix qui dit nous
croyons à la valeur travail nous croyons
que le travail fait progresser la
société et qu'à la fin d'une vie la
société sera capable par le travail par
le travail de payer sa propre retraite
et de ne pas dire aux gens
mettez de côté chacun de votre côté ce
sera mieux parce que la société elle ne
vous garantit rien à la fin quelle est
la sottise que voulait construire
finalement une société de solidarité ou
une société égoïste qui n'est plus une
société voulez vous croyez croyez vous à
la valeur travail si vous croyez à
valeur travail
alors il faut croire que le travail
enrichit la société permet la solidarité
et c'est le système par répartition
merci mon cher collègue les explications
de vote je n'envoie plus donc je me te
vois l'amendement 246 si je rappelle la
commission gouvernement a émis des avis
défavorables succès favorablement vous
deviez levez la main ceux qui sont
défavorables
il n'est pas adopté je suis saisi de
l'amendement 11 rectifié bis et vous
madame lienemann milman c'est voulons
rectifier vi
chers collègues j'aurai l'occasion de
l'indiquer je ne suis pas favorable à
l'allongement de la durée des
cotisations et d'ailleurs j'ai déposé
des amendements en ce sens je suis tout
à fait hostile depuis toujours au
passage je rappellerai à mes collègues
pour ma part quand je suis dans
l'opposition je prends des décisions et
des orientations que j'estime fait
réalisable quand je suis quand la gauche
est au pouvoir
je n'ai donc à peser toujours la même
critique sur les réformes qui ont été
faites par monsieur balladur qui ont été
faites par monsieur raffarin qui ont été
faites par monsieur fillon ou par
monsieur juppé elle était mauvaise elles
ont pas résolu les problèmes et ils ont
accru les inégalités et affaiblit nos
retraités pour ma part quoi qu'il en
soit je garde la même analyse et je
reste fidèle à ce que j'ai toujours voté
à savoir que nous sommes contre
l'allongement des cotisations sociales à
partir du moment d'autant plus que nous
avons un chômage de masse qui percute
notre jeunesse donc pour ma part je suis
hostile à cela en revanche
indépendamment du fait que j'y suis
hostile je crains toutefois que cette
mesure soit réalisée et à l'instar de ce
qu'avait fait mon collègue jean marc
germain à l'assemblée nationale
je pense qu'il ya un garde fou qu'il
faut mettre pour l'avenir qui est le
fait suivant à savoir que chaque
génération doit avoir un âge de départ
qui offrent une durée de retraite au
moins égale à la moitié de la durée
d'activité professionnelle
alors vous allez me dire comme vous
l'avez dit à mon collègue jean marc
germain que actuellement c'est le cas
c'est le cas en moyenne s'est satisfait
pour aujourd'hui mais comme il vous est
pas et il n'est pas à l'article
à nous pas nous fixons le cas de notre
régime de retraite et donc ce qui est
vérifié aujourd'hui ne l'est pas
forcément demain pour plusieurs raisons
la première c'est d'abord que nous avons
dans la période récente gagner si je
puis dire
deux années de travail moyenne pour
partir en retraite en dix ans de 2001 à
2002 enfin neuf ans de 2000 à 2010 la
durée
deux départs en retraite l'âge moyen à
gagner deux ans pour autant nous n'avons
pas dans la même période
gagner en tout cas pour tous deux années
de vie et donc en fait se creusent un
décalage entre l'espérance de vie qu'on
gagne et l'espère la durée de travail
d'année où l'on se trouve
ce qui d'ailleurs au passage est un
risque majeur puisque même ceux qui
étaient proposés dans les textes c'était
les 2/3 1/3 2/3 de gain en travail et un
tiers pour les retraites a minima a
minima minimum ça devrait être du 50 %
il n'est pas acceptable que l'humanité
qui je m'excuse on a l'air de découvrir
quelque chose de neuf
on vit plus longtemps on travaille moins
longtemps mais c'est séculaire depuis
que l'humanité existe on vit plus
longtemps et on travaille moins
longtemps et c'est ça le progrès humain
et je vois pas pourquoi en 2009 2010
2011 2014
d'un seul coup il faudrait qu'on
découvre qu'on inverse donne est par
ailleurs ça jamais été la gauche qu'à
allonger la durée des cotisations et le
temps de travail dans ce pays
alors première chose les années de vie
qu'on gagne ne sont plus celles sont
essentiellement consacrée au travail
bonjour le progrès deuxièmement la durée
de vie baisse pour certains pays car
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire
plus on travaille longtemps - on vit
longtemps sans compter qu'on vire à
moins autant bonne santé c'est un sujet
que j'évoquais au moment de la de
l'amendement 2 3 m en dos comme la durée
de vie risque décès et que la durée de
cotisations risquent de monter dans la
durée on peut avoir une divergence entre
le temps où on va travailler et le temps
va bénéficier de la retraite
et troisièmement et elle la durée
d'activité de nos jeunes est menacé
parce que à mesure et là on le voit bien
dans les courbes
à partir de 2008 2009 on voit une montée
en flèche durant entre guillemets du du
travail des seniors
ce dont on pourrait se réjouir mais le
seul problème
c'est que dans le même camp temps on
voit baisser en symétrique
la courbe du travail des actifs et des
jeunes et plus encore des jeunes donc
nous sommes dans un mécanisme ou à terme
la durée d'activité partant plus
longtemps et comme on va être obligés de
travailler plus longtemps
le temps de retraite va se retrouver à
être grignoté par rapport au temps de
travail alors je le dis bien
personnellement je me contenterai de
l'abandon de l'amendement 2 mais en
l'état de ce que je peux percevoir de
fait que dans cette loi l'allongement
risque d'être conservés il y aurait au
moins une mesure de précaution à terme
qui viserait à fixer ce clic et que la
durée moyenne de la retraite est au
moins égale à la moitié de la durée de
l'activité professionnelle merci à vis
de la commission
mais monsieur le président madame la
ministre
chaque collègue votre âme au mans entend
prévoir que le système de retraite
garanti une durée de retraite au moins
égale vous l'avez rappelé dans votre
explication d'un moment à la moitié de
la durée de l'activité professionnelle
la prison compte de l'espérance de vie
est déjà prévue à l'alinéa l'alinéa 6 de
l'article 1er est elle figure parmi les
paramètres au regard desquels le comité
de suivi formulera chaque année des
recommandations public
aussi la commission madame la sénatrice
vous demande de retirer votre abandon
sinon elle émet un avis défavorable
merci à vis du gouvernement madame le
ministre
oui monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice
je donnerai de façon cohérente avec le
reste du texte un avis défavorable à
votre amendement souci vous le referiez
quelle est la logique de notre tête j'ai
bien entendu vos arguments et les
objectifs que vous poursuiviez mais dans
le texte que je vous présente il y a
d'abord à l'article 1 celui que nous
examinons la réaffirmation du principe
de système de retraite par répartition
et donc nous rappelons de façon tout à
fait explicite que l'équité la
solidarité constitue les fondements de
notre système de retraite dans le même
temps nous voulons marquer notre
détermination pour ce qui est de la
durée d'assurance en là en mettant en
avant trois principes la prévisibilité
pas ce qui nous paraît absolument
nécessaire que nos concitoyens sachent à
quoi s'en tenir
la justice et l'équité donc oui
l'article 2 prévoit l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation on en discutera mais
il l'a prévoit d'une manière qui est
prévisible puisque c'est à partir de
2020 et à un rythme qui est déterminé
défini dans la loi et selon des critères
qui seront modulées pour tenir compte
deux des caractéristiques de la vie
professionnelle
par ailleurs cette hausse de la durée de
cotisation donc est inscrite dans la loi
ce qui signifie que toute évolution
cette durée de cotisation devrait faire
l'objet d'un passage au parlement dans
quelque sens que ce soit d'ailleurs et
l'article 3 prévoit un système de suivi
qui
n'écarte pas la possibilité par le
comité de suivi de faire de
recommandations portant sur la durée de
cotisation mais pour que ces
recommandations dans un sens ou dans un
autre
j'insiste puisse déboucher sur une
quelconque décision
il faudrait en passer par la loi et donc
il me semble que les objectifs qui sont
les vôtres si je laisse de côté la
question de principe sur l'allongement
de la durée de cotisation on en
discutera à l'article 2 mai que les
objectifs qui sont les vôtres réaffirmé
le principe de solidarité introduire de
la lisibilité ou de la prévisibilité
tenir compte des situations de la
carrière professionnelle faire en sorte
qu' il y à un contrôle par le pouvoir
politique à travers le passage au
parlement ces objectifs là ils sont
inscrits dans la loi
c'est pour cela que votre amendement ne
me semble pas apporté d'éléments
nouveaux par rapport au dispositif tel
qu'il est prévu qu'un ministre mme naima
nouveau commandement est maintenue
président je le maintiens parce que je
ne vois pas en quoi fixer le cadre de
balises qui évite que le politique
décide parce que le budget serait pas
bon parce qu'on manque d'argent et c'est
qu'à certains moments et ben finalement
tant pis si on allonge a duré plus que
ce qu'on va bénéficier de la retraite
je pense qu'à minima ça me paraît une
balise normale en jeu je risque d'être
assez seul car j'imagine que mes
collègues qui sont hostiles à
l'allongement pouvait être tenté de ne
pas voter cet amendement
néanmoins je pense que je prend date
pour l'histoire et ça me paraît quand
même en cohérence avec beaucoup des
combats que j'ai menés et que nous avons
menées au sein du parti socialiste
depuis de nombreuses années monsieur le
noir mais monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues en
l'espace de deux amendements on voit le
décalage qu'il ya entre le pragmatisme
le réalisme le bon sens et la rêverie
il y un instant il y à la rêverie
il y a un instant est un instant un
amendement de bon sens souligné qu'il
fallait en france un système obligatoire
par répartition un système obligatoire
de retraite complémentaire et le cas
échéant un régime par capitalisation
franchement voté contre tel amendement
me surprend et surprendra ceux qui
liront nos débats et aussitôt après ma
collègue madame lienemann pour laquelle
j'ai le plus grand respect est en train
d'inventer un système qui est à la fois
audacieux et généreux audacieux parce
que vous voulez par une disposition
législative dire qu'une personne doit
avoir une retraite qui représente la
moitié de son temps de travail
c'est évidemment généreux c'est
évidemment généreux puisque à l'issue de
40 42 ans de travail
vous voulez de par la loi donnait une
assurance vie une assurance vie qui
permettent à la personne qui a travaillé
de vivre ainsi pendant longtemps
pour ma part je vous en remercie
d'ailleurs je cotise depuis l'âge de 18
ans veut écouter si on vote cet
amendement et je vous prête évidemment
un pouvoir considérable que certains
jugeront peut-être surnaturel je peux
envisager de vivre une longue retraite
mais comme si madame lienemann c'est la
loi qui pouvaient fixer
hélas hélas soyez un peu réaliste 2
demain demain l'un d'entre nous peut
disparaître comme disparaîtront des
français qui n'entre pas du tout dans le
mécanisme que vous avez proposé de grâce
ne
trompez pas l'opinion française en
laissant en tant que c'est par la loi
qu'on peut assurer ainsi au delà de la
période d'activité la moitié de vie
paisible d'un retraité chez café merci
monsieur le président je voudrais dire à
ma collègue marie noëlle lienemann
keupon je ne sais pas si elle prend date
pour l'histoire mais que en tout cas
s'agissant d'histoire je ne partage pas
sa vision optimiste de l'histoire de
l'humanité
car contrairement à ce que vous dites
jean marie noëlle je ne crois pas que
l'histoire de l'humanité était un long
mouvement vers la diminution du temps de
travail et l'augmentation du temps passé
à la retraite dans le bonheur je crois
même je crois même que ce phénomène dont
vous parlez madame d'une manne est un
phénomène extrêmement récent qui datent
du 19e siècle avec les premières mois
avec les premières lois sociales avec la
mise en place des assurances sociales
les premières en europe par bismarck
voyez-vous et que auparavant c'était où
ont travaillé toute sa vie
ou alors on n'avait pas de retraite en
tout cas si on avait une retraite ou si
on voulait arrêter de travailler il
n'avait pas d'assurance sociale donc
recadrons un peu le débat quand même sur
la longue marche de l'humanité vers le
temps heureux
à la retraite ça n'est pas vrai il a
fallu attendre le 19e siècle et il a
fallu attendre
en france les premières lois celle de
1910 comme je le disais tout à l'heure
les retraites ouvrières et paysannes par
capitalisation
lesquels avaient été combattue si je me
souviens bien par jour est ce bon non
non c'est non celle inverse
bon donc c'est un phénomène qui est
extrêmement récent et où en sommes-nous
maintenant parce que c'est ça qui compte
madame lienemann
où en sommes nous maintenant c'est ça la
question qui nous est posée
j'ai la conviction peut être agressif
doit vérifier que le clic et que vous
voulez mettre est aujourd'hui une
réalité objective une réalité objective
et d'ailleurs je voudrais vous faire
part d'un argument c'est que cette loi
avec l'article 4 2 je me souviens plus
la durée de cotisation
2 est plus protectrice que la
législation antérieure celle de 2003
que dit la législation de 2003 elle dit
il faut maintenir un rapport constant
entre le temps passé au travail est la
durée de retraite bas et ceci de manière
indéfinie et c'est un décret c'est un
décret pris par le gouvernement qui pour
chaque génération dès lors qu'elle
atteint 58 ans définit le temps de
cotisation et la durée de cotisation et
donc vous pouvez très bien avoir un
système où jusqu'à l'année 2100 vous
pouvez avoir
ce mécanisme qui fonctionne alors que la
loi un avantage par rapport à la loi
actuelle a un avantage par rapport aux
mécanismes de 2003 c'est qu'elle met un
terme à ce mécanisme
elle met un terme à l'horizon 2035 et
elle dit à partir de la génération 1973
on ira plus loin que 43 ans avec le
mécanisme est d'ailleurs ce avaient été
expertisés par le rapport de yannick
moreau avec le mécanisme de la loi de
2003 on pouvait aller
pour la génération par exemple 1989 on
pouvait aller jusqu'à 44 années de
cotisation obligatoire sans avoir la
certitude que le rapport que vous voulez
imposer par la loi serait observé donc
je crois que votre amendement est
satisfait je crois que la loi à l'heure
actuelle va plus loin que celle de 2003
c'est-à-dire qu'elle met un terme à
l'augmentation de durée de cotisation et
c'est la raison pour laquelle
personnellement je ne voterai pas votre
amendement voilà donc pour la séance
d'hier soir les sénateurs en sont donc
toujours à l'examen de l'article premier
du texte qui porte sur les objectifs du
système de retraites
vous pouvez bien sûr toujours revoir
toutes les séances sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
parlementaire cet après-midi
vingt-quatre heures sénat à 17 heures
toujours sur l'examen du projet de loi
sur les retraites
très bonne journée sur la chaîne
parlementaire